courtesy of westwood one iron eagle with
the call the great analysis
by ross tucker who's kind enough to join
us this is your do you believe in
miracles moment ross tucker with
you you summed it up without saying a
word congratulations
thank you dan i appreciate that it's
funny you know this as well as anyone
right
you're taught as a color commentator to
never
step on the play-by-play guy right you
let the play-by-play guy
make the call you don't ruin the moment
it's especially the case in radio
because people can't see what's going on
then i couldn't help it i i couldn't
help it and afterwards
i said that i an eagle and my producer
howie denneroff i said
guys i'm sorry and they said absolutely
not that was great that was authentic
that was genuine
because i know dan you're not suppo
you're not quote-unquote supposed to do
that
but that might have been the funniest
thing i've ever seen on an
nfl football field you just don't see
that
and you could see it coming for 15 yards
the rest of the clip i said i'm sorry
but i saw it coming from 15 yards he got
out
over his skis which i thought was the
best way to describe it
you're you're supposed to use words but
no matter what the words were they
weren't going to capture
the moment and that's why when you say
hey i just laughed you were like we were
laughing with you
at the time so i i wouldn't feel bad
about it
i think if you're gonna describe
something
you described it perfectly by just
laughing
yeah you know what it's kind of like um
on social media
and text messages you know how like
emojis
are better a lot of times than any words
you can put you know the tears
or shrug or whatever i guess that's what
the laughing was i'm getting a lot of
people texting me and tweets at ross
tucker nfl
about it i got to be honest with you dan
i am just very happy
that the giant scored a touchdown on
that drive
can you ima i've met daniel jones he's a
good young man
can you imagine if the giants lost in
the fashion that they lost
but that they had had to settle for a
field goal on that drive i mean he
already feels bad enough they lost
and he had an all-time stumble but it
would have been even
worse if they didn't score a touchdown
there
and then one other thing i'll point out
we confirmed this last night
that was history last night dan that was
the longest
non-scoring run for a quarterback
since at least the merger in the nfl
the longest non-scoring run and i saw
where ian rappaport
just tweeted that it was the fastest run
by a quarterback
in a couple of years which you're like
wait a minute how could he be faster
than lamar jackson but
i got i guess he got up to 21.5 miles
per hour
and got over his skis a little bit
i go back to i think mark malone does
mark malone hold the record paulie did
you
you remember the steeler quarterback
mark malone yes i think he had like a
upper 80s low 90 yard touchdown run
uh in in a game i think he might have
the longest record
did you guys know he did he did i think
though
terrell pryor when he was starting a
quarterback for the raiders went
90 something against okay okay i think
terrell pryor knocked
mark malone out of the um record out of
the record and trump probably not even
really a quarterback but he was for a
few games for the raiders so i guess he
gets credit for that
and you know i looked at this and i know
daniel jones and will laugh at this and
and it's going to stay with him the rest
of his career evan
ingram is the one who should be
embarrassed because if he makes that
catch
that jones put it right in his hands
they win this game
that to me is more embarrassing than
what daniel jones did
you know jones is not used to running 80
yards
evan ingram is a tight end catch the
ball you win the game
well and earlier than that dan uh there
was a blitz daniel jones threw it to
ingram
it popped right off ingram's chest and
that was the jalen mills
interception ingram's a really talented
kid
he just can't put it together and daniel
joe said that that's one right there
i'm okay with talking about wins and
losses
as a quarterback stat it's not a great
stat it's not even a good stat
but i'm okay mentioning it but that's
one right there
daniel jones did what he had to do he
put it
right in the basket for evan ingram
and so here's the thing the daniel jones
thing dan
that's funny the evan ingram thing
there's nothing funny about that at all
i mean that that's just
awful for a professional tight end to
drop that pass
you're at west point today i am
and i'm doing the army game tomorrow
it's my fifth one this year
and i have heard you wax poetic about it
multiple times i love it i'm at the
thayer hotel
on campus overlooking buffalo
soldier field which is where uh the
cadets do a lot of their intramural
sports would you like to see it dan
yes i would all right ross joining us
and there it is oh look at the foliage
there
wow i like it and i've stayed at that
hotel
and you can walk over to the stadium you
can walk on campus there
that's a treat yeah so you see that
field right there that field that i was
just showing yeah
and you know this for home games
typically
it's all cars it's all par it's it's all
cars and they're tailgating
and and the gate you have to go through
the security gate to get on
on post as you know it's usually backed
up for
miles dan it's been eerie to wake up on
saturday mornings
not a single solitary car
not one car trying to get through the
gate because they're not allowing fans
other than the cadets i'm just glad the
cadets are there
because they bring the energy it's been
cool to have some energy at the game
paulie and i were just discussing during
the commercial break
could can we get in if we go up
yeah i think you probably could i i
think you could get a
media day pass because there are people
that come you guys are media
i am i'm media
would be my plus one i don't think that
you would uh
i don't think they'd have you sit in the
stands but i think that they would have
a socially distant spot for you
in like you know the press box or the
luxury box
i mean come on dan you're dan patrick
i'm pretty sure i can text the ad
if you want me to but uh it's i texted
um
paulie i tweeted paul a couple weeks ago
he said we were six days away
from peak foliage paulie's starting a
new company that you just
you text him where you are and he'll
tell you the exact
day of foliage for that town so i think
i think we might have peak foliage so
check out
cbs sports network tomorrow at noon
thank you bud
we appreciate it my pleasure thanks for
having me that's right ross tucker he'll
be on the call army against mercer